évoqué à présent Lucas une erreur
médicale de taille une patiente de
l'hôpital Bretonneau prise en charge
pour un cancer du sein a été irradié sur
le mauvais côté pendant 25 séances après
s'en être rendu compte les
professionnels de santé ont signalé
l'erreur à l'Autorité de sûreté nucléire
celle-ci a estimé qu'à ce niveau la
patiente a peu de chance d'avoir des
séquelles une affaire sur laquelle s'est
exprimé l'hôpital aujourd'hui clémon
doosk et Natalia schkourenko étaient sur
place comment une telle erreur est-elle
possible ici au centre régional de
cancérologie près de 20000
radiothérapies sont effectuées chaque
année mais au printemps 2023 une
patiente s'est rendu compte qu'elle
était traitée du mauvais côté pour un
cancer du sein la direction de l'hôpital
est revenue sur cet accident à
l'écédiatique nationale les équipes
médicaux-signantes du CHU donc
représenté ici par le professeur
Barillot le président de CME et la toute
la direction de l'établissement donc
tiennent à renouveler leur profond
engagement vers la la sécurité de chaque
passti
et tiennent à à souligné leur
détermination à à tirer les les
enseignements de cet événement donc pour
renforcer davantage leur protocole et
garantir la la plus haute qualité de
soins que qui est due à à nos patients
c'est suite à l'apparition de lésion sur
sa peau que l'erreur a été détectée
l'incident a été remonté à l'Agence
nationale de sûreté nucléaire il est
classé de niveau 2 7 étant le plus
important les jours de la patiente ne
sont pas en danger et le préjudice est
qualifié de modérer
à un moment donné de l'étape de
préparation où on dessine le volume à
traiter il va y avoir un contrôle
multidisciplinaire de ce qui a été
dessiné ce qui n'existait pas auparavant
et il va y avoir alors que nous le
faisions à l'initiation du traitement
l'interrogation de la patiente ou du
patient sur le côté à traiter et bien
nous allons réitérer cette interrogation
à chaque séance de traitement ni la
patiente ni les équipes ne se sont rendu
compte plutôt de cette erreur la
radiothérapie est effectuée dans une
machine semblable à celle pour les REM
du côté du CHU on assure que les mesures
de prévention sont déjà robustes mais
qu'elles seront renforcées sur certains
points aucune plainte n'a été déposé par
la
patiente